yeah good evening or afternoon and
lovely afternoon welcome first I want to
remind everyone just to maintain the
loveliness of our opening audiology if
you could turn off your cellphone's that
would be a great way to begin this
ritual event my name is Katherine often
and I teach in the history of religions
here at Yale University I want to
welcome you to this the third lecture in
a four lecture series of this year's
dwight h terry lectureship this year's
terry lectures are being given by philip
pitcher currently teaching at Columbia
University and their Department of
Philosophy where he holds an appointment
as the John Dewey professor of
philosophy an auspicious title which in
the opening lecture Dale Martin pointed
out that doing himself was the first
person to give the lectures in this
series since professor Kuchar has
already been introduced twice in this
series with preambles that beautifully
emphasized his enormous list of
accomplishments academic appointments
notable awards significant editorial
stewardship and intellectual
contributions I'm going to defer for now
those proper noun Laden remarks trust
that all of you possess Google in your
disposal you can quickly stand in the
very true awe at the totems a professor
catcher is remarkable career
constitutional service and philosophical
significance instead I want to offer a
very brief omage to the kind of
intellectual that professor catcher is I
first encountered professor catcher and
though it may seem serious I'm a scholar
of American religious history why do I
stand here today and the reason is that
I revealed to Professor Dale Martin the
following strange biographical fact that
in the late 1990s I as then a late
adolescent was a typical I think of
perhaps people in this room a late
adolescent
nerd gobbling up very popular nerd
publications like the London Review of
Books I would receive the LRB and the NY
RB and bundles from a family for which I
was an occasional au-pair and I would
sit for very long heathen Sunday's
gorging on their contents during the
same time period pitcher had an
occasional appearance in the LRB
offering diagnosis on a subject that was
at the time very close to my late
adolescent heart the question of
evolution biology in concepts of the
self in those essays pitcher already an
established academic philosopher
although I hardly knew that at the time
spoke to the absolute nub of every
problem he found quickly cutting away
the ill logic of this or that scientific
Shibboleth with a knowledge that seemed
to my young eye is the very definition
of the total intellectual he was Rai
sure and he had a kind of rhetorical
panache but more importantly to me he
seemed so clear eyed before the
grandiose world and its confusion of
obnoxious interpretations a review of
pitchers writing which this occasions
have offered me the opportunity to
peruse shows that time and again he
walked into material and too knotty
thickets and carefully straightens out
their cords chatting amiably to you the
reader above this nonsense
as he does so you begin any kitchen buck
or article feeling very sure about the
meanings of words in their world's
scientific ethical literary but by the
end you feel certain that you were also
quite formally confused and now have
been righted by somebody who carries
every tool in his toolbox there may be
in our I think many words for this kind
of graceful thinker but for the purposes
of our contemporary humanist moment I
want to celebrate Philip pitcher and
most particularly as an
interdisciplinary artist as somebody for
whom the questions of our time simply
cannot be conceived merely through
transom when
those we need kaleidoscope eyes to parry
with the problems of self body science
history philanthropy and community our
disciplines discipline us absolutely
but like all martial disciplines they
cannot be useful if we can only follow
their paces and regulated forms at the
beginning of classes at the same time
that I was discovering pitcher in the
LRB a group of Frenchmen calling
themselves the yarmulke see group
developed parkour a kind of Street
gymnastics and which highly trained
individuals move quickly through urban
environments using complex material fact
of the city as their leverage and
inspiration YouTube that later parkour
today we will hear professor catcher's
third lecture in the tairy series titled
mortality and meaning and we will get to
watch what I think of as parkour and
rhetorical form as Professor kitch ER
uses concepts from the world to make
sense of it with incomparable agility
and careful grace please help me welcome
professor catcher again to Yale
University
but thank you for that lovely
introduction in 1868 two years after
he'd finished the six movements
originally planned for his German
Requiem Brahms in thirty-two seventh a
soprano solo punctuated by muted
interjections from the chorus you just
heard that at least in the background
the text he chose promises consolation
those who grieve will be comforted the
bereaved will again see those they have
lost Brahms is setting responds to the
mourners sorrow with gestures of
exquisite tenderness music-loving
secularists however resolute their non
belief should concede it's emotional
power culturally successful religions
are often credited with enabling their
followers to understand and to accept
the major transitions in human life
they've had plenty of practice typically
centuries or millennia in which they've
shaped their rites those like
Christianity and Islam that promise an
eternal continuation to which mundane
human life is a prayer you'd seem
specially adept at coping with the last
transition death is supposedly easier
for the devout to bear part of the
relief comes from prospects of personal
continuation and hopes for reunion with
others who have been loved and lost
consolation also flows from faith in a
link between human individuals and the
transcendent a connection that confers
upon each human life and eternal
significance for the non-believer
however there's no hope of future
survival or of reclaiming the dead
individual human lives are thoroughly
finite their effects evanescent all
human life will eventually cease human
finer tude leaves nothing to celebrate
in the wake of the human
what uses Darwin at a Funeral mortality
and meaning raised connected challenges
to secular humanism I'm going to try to
show that many of the difficulties are
more apparent than real
how should a secular humanists think
about the prospect of his own death
a classic recommendation sees fear as
inappropriate with death will come the
end of pain of suffering of frustrated
striving Hamlet meditating suicide calls
death a consummation devoutly to be
wish'd
until turning suddenly devout he
imagines an afterlife in which the
torments of mundane existence continue
secularists who dismiss that possibility
can avoid Hamlet's anxious retreat being
dead is nothing to be frightened of but
there's the getting there fear can be
directed not toward the state itself but
at the process of dying people are often
afraid not only of the pains that come
at the end but also of the unraveling of
body and mind so they're terrified at
the thought of what they are likely to
become for seeing the surviving being as
a grotesque parody of themselves these
concerns deserve support from those who
might help them avoid or at least
mitigate the conditions they fear
support need not and probably should not
come from religion but from humane
deployment of medical resources careful
thoughts about the end should be
expressed developed in end-of-life
conversations designed to allow death to
approximate a person's reflective image
of her life secular humanists regret
that religious affiliations and indeed
religious interventions all too often
override people's anxieties about the
inevitable ending yet maybe I focused on
the wrong emotion as you look forward to
the future the world without you you
might feel regret not fear being sad
that you will no longer be a part of the
show the ancients offered reassurance
as you look back into the past you
contemplate with equanimity the long
expanse of time before you were born
no pangs disturb you as you think about
your absence from particular historical
episodes why should you feel any
differently about the future answer that
supposedly rhetorical question with
another question do you feel differently
about your absence from different parts
of the future I do as I imagine the
world in the years immediately following
my death I'm far more regretful than
when I contemplate the more distant
future increasing the time interval
diminishes my sadness it fades
asymptotically and relatively swiftly to
indifference why is that not I think
because of some quirk of my psychology
nor because I'm envious of those who
live happily and actively into extreme
old age I don't even learn for the
longevity that advances in medicine
might someday achieve for future
generations absence from the period just
after my death is poignant because so
much of the stuff of my life will
continue in it whenever I die people
about whom I care most will live on and
I should like to be there sustaining
them and being sustained by them
endeavors to which I have committed my
energies will remain unfinished
by contrast the connections with the
more distant future a dim and I can't
even be confident of the large contours
of the remote world from which I'll be
excluded were I to survive into that
world there would be a continuously
evolving set of relationships and
activities to give me a stake in it but
in the absence of any experience of that
development of my life the concerns I
would come to have aren't vivid for me
so as I look forward sufficiently far
regret declines into indifference the
loss of the immediate future is hard for
those whose lives attain or approach the
biblically allotted span but for the
young who face the threat of imminent
death the sorrow is even more intense no
member of their unfortunate reign
to express the predicament more
eloquently than Keats when I have fears
that I may cease to be before my pen has
gleaned my teeming brain before high
pilot books in character II hold like
rich ganas the full ripened grain regret
and sadness become fear but the fear
isn't of death in general that's nothing
to be frightened of premature death
however is fearsome even terrifying
because it truncates and nullifies the
pattern of the life although the later
lines of the sonnet worried that he will
never experience the love for which he
yearns keeps his first anxiety is the
expression of his genius central to his
existence is his poetic vocation if that
vocation were realized only in a
mutilated abbreviated form the meaning
of his life would be lost for secular
humanism the genuine problem of death is
the problem of premature death deaths
counters premature when they prevent
lives from attaining meaning the
challenges of mortality and meaning
connect but you might think on all
deaths premature can any finite life be
meaningful a proposal human lives
sometimes attained meaning through
individuals developing conceptions of
who they are
and what matters to their existences
through their pursuit of the goals
endorsed by those conceptions and
through some degree of success in
attaining them a Keats who live for 80
years piling up books full of poetry as
extraordinary as the lyrics he wrote at
the height of his powers would have led
a meaningful life whether or not he'd
found love along the way indeed the
actual kids leaving only a fraction of
what he might have written lived a life
whose meaning is untouched by his early
death nor is exceptional achievement
needed secularists should endorse not
only the grand accomplishments of the
poets and the statesmen and the
scientists but also the humblest self
conceptions of those whose pursuits and
achievements focus more
luckily on family on friendship on
community on the maintenance of things
that matter to a small group of other
people mattering to others is what
counts in conferring meaning keeps
matters to others because of a body of
verse that continues to delight the
effects of more ordinary lives have felt
on a smaller scale but they can secure
genuine work the shape of the dispute
between the secular humanist position
and the religious perspective should now
be visible for the religious challenger
no set of characteristics of finite
lives or of relations among finite lives
can substitute for the connection to the
transcendent
that alone confers meaning and value
problems about our own deaths lead as
I've tried to show to deeper issues
about the significance of finite lives
yet the thought that we shall cease to
be isn't the only way death figures as a
problem for us the loss of loved ones
lacks secular compensation in the
beginning the fabric of the human life
is tightly woven all the threads tying
us together a fully intact as people
grow and others die holes appear leaving
frayed ends that can't be reconnected
for those who live the longest
the final tapestry as a thing of shreds
and tatters it's yearning vacancies
recalling people whose laughter and
whose touch is still long for growing
old besides someone you love brings the
overwhelmingly likely prospect of an
ending in which one will mourn the loss
of the other and the inevitable
shrinking of the survivors life is for
both parties more fearsome than the
anticipation of one's own bodily and
mental decay back then to Brahms and the
promise of reunion here apparently is a
consolation secular humanism can't match
a hope religious widows and widowers
sometimes confess they couldn't forfeit
well-meaning people occasionally tender
a similar hope to those who grieve
children as Charles Kingsley did in a
letter to his friend thomas henry huxley
Huxley had lost his beloved first son
Knoll at the age of four and Kingsley
the Reverend Charles Kingsley regretted
that the celebrated agnostic couldn't
look forward to a reunion with the boy
in heaven
despite his grief Huxley responded with
an unflinching declaration of his
resolve to serve imagine for a moment
that Kings his vision of the hereafter
was correct would his promise of a
future meeting have provided what his
friends so desperately wanted I don't
think so
no such reunion would have extended the
threads death had broken
Huck's his life had been into woven with
that of his child he'd anticipated
guiding the boy through his formative
years watching him mature into an adult
gradually fashioning a new more equal
relationship with Knowle looking on as
the young man created his own pattern
for his life parents who have lost their
children lovers who mourn the beloved
people who miss a close friend want a
continuation here and now not a meeting
under very different dimly imaginable
conditions in which two strangers their
lives no longer connected confront one
another the whole in life's fabric
demands immediate repair my religious
challengers likely to protest the
dismissal of the promised comfort rests
on misunderstanding the character of the
afterlife on substituting a crude vision
that undermines the real consolation yet
mistaken as they may be about the
glories of the hereafter the bereaved
are surely clear about the aching gap
they feel in their lives
whatever happens in the future there's a
loss in the mundane present moreover
purified religion with its abstract
indescribable transcendent cannot
deliver much reassurance for Kingsley's
hope or anything similar to respond in
any fashion to the sorrows of the
bereaved it
must rest on substantive religious
doctrines the words Brahm set must be
heard is importing the everyday
implications of Vida zein to see again
although Christians often express
disdain for the material comforts the
Paradise the Quran holds out to Muslims
the Islamic vision has the merit of
connecting with the desires of the
faithful when religion retreats to
confessing the transcendent is a mystery
only apprehensible through figurative
suggestions it's advertised power to
bring comfort in the wake of death
dissolves Huxley was right to judge that
the crumbs of comfort Kingsly offered
depended on swallowing a fiction on
forsaking the devotion to truth purified
religion does little better with respect
to your own death first whatever the
qualities of the envisaged continuation
present losses remain projects some of
them important are left unfinished if
the compensation offered is a life in
which suffering is behind you in which
there's an end to challenges and an end
to struggle the promise has a
superficial appeal but only until you
reflect that individual identities are
founded in commitments in goals people
struggle to realize we may envisage of
being psychologically continuous with
ourselves no longer invested in anything
we have taken to be significant or
central but it's hard to regard that
being as any one we will want to become
or to celebrate its existence as a
splendid continuation of our own
purified religion with its restrained
conception of the transcendent can't
even assume that the survivor will live
in a condition of unimaginable bliss in
the end the familiar thoughts that
religion provides responses to problems
posed by our mortality responses greatly
superior to anything secular humanism
can offer our distractions the jives
about Darwin's uselessness at funerals
grounded in misunderstanding the human
situation death should usually be an
occasion for sorrow
either on a religious or a secular
account if Brahms is soprano uplifts our
heroes for a moment that's because the
music she sings is beautiful and its
sensitivity to the words reminds us
vividly of things that are valuable
within human life the real challenge to
secularism focuses on meaning and fine
attune the problem is not where the
secularists can match the religious
response to death but whether they can
make adequate sense of life the question
of the good life is the oldest issue of
Western philosophy one that drew the
privileged young man of the ancient
world to the various philosophical
schools their mentors instructed them in
techniques for living well learn and
practice virtue be active in political
life cultivate friendships pursue
knowledge for its own sake limit
pleasures to those maintaining
psychological equilibrium and so forth
contemporary judgment might expand the
catalog and undo the distortions imposed
by conceiving the good life is only
possible for a privileged elite after
the fall of Rome however the old
philosophical question lapsed in the
intellectual culture of the West for it
seemed to have received a definitive
solution the Christian churches declared
that the valuable life is one centered
on obedience to God's commandments and
rewarded by an eternal continuation the
finite span of earthly life is only a
prelude it's worth determined by whether
it fits us for eternity the
Enlightenment revived interest in the
ancient problem secular thinkers
endorsed the importance of many of the
qualities highlighted in the classical
tradition reacting to a prominent
feature of the religious conception of
the meaningful life the outside
imposition of meaning on the individual
some thinkers Kant
Humboldt and mill notable among them
emphasized the importance of autonomy
for a life to be meaningful the person
must have some conception of who she is
and what aspirations are most important
and this conception
must not be imposed from without in
Mills classic formulation the highest
form of freedom is to pursue one's own
good in one's own way each meaningful
life is distinguished by a theme a
conception of the self and a concomitant
identification of the goals its most
important to pursue that theme should be
autonomously chosen by the person whose
life it is but we shouldn't over
interpret the talk of themes and an
autonomous choice meaningful lives
aren't restricted to the privileged few
to an elite of the high-minded it's
wrong to suppose that there has to be a
transformative event an epiphany around
16 say when a condition of detached
freedom permits the review of a large
range of options and identification with
exactly one of them in a commitment
never to be amended or revoked someone's
life theme may not be formulated
explicitly unless or until a question
requires what matters most to her her
autonomy may consist in the presence of
different possibilities and in the
absence of the everyday ways in which
people are often coerced to assume the
tasks and roles that form and dominate
their lives
moreover the theme itself may evolve
under the contingent conditions
generated from previous pursuits
originally centered on nurturing her
children a mother bears an infant who
needs a particular kind of help and
through learning how to provide the
necessary support she comes to devote
herself to assisting similar children
are there further constraints on life
themes beyond the requirement autonomous
voice the Enlightenment thinkers
believed there were casting the
classical emphasis on virtue as the
demand that themes be ethically
permissible Mill limits his fundamental
form of freedom one person's choices and
pursuits of his own good mustn't
interfere with the kindred choices and
pursuits of others that constraint
should be accepted but it's too weak
many projects posing no threat to the
life patterns and the lives of others
would be insignificant worthless imagine
for example in a social solitaire
retreating to some remote place and
pausing his days and counting the blades
of grass in his vicinity lives like that
are wasted so - as I'll contend later
are others all too common in the
affluent world in which people center
their lives on the pursuit of material
possessions their self conception summed
up in a bumper sticker he who dies with
the most toys wins lives matter when
they touch others the impress of the
ethical project should be felt more
definitely in the individuals choice of
self conception the problem of limited
responsiveness was and remains the
center of ethical practice and
individual lives gained meaning through
their own contributions to solving that
problem through actions prompted by
recognizing what other people want or
need and attempting to provide the
things required ethical values I
suggested last Thursday our social
creations worked out collectively to
address a basic problem of the human
situation the meanings of lives are
individual creations products of
people's autonomous choices but framed
always by the core ethical ideal of
other directedness is there they no
place for the meaningful life founded on
the development of special talent of
genius that dedicates itself to
self-expression indeed there is for the
demand for other directedness is met if
talent and Express genius are to be
worthy of the names keeps his fears of
death is truncating the expression as
genius already connected what he hoped
to write with the lives of others he
foresaw high pilot books as granaries to
nourish his readers if his writings had
failed to move or illuminate others or
if he had resolved that his verse should
be confined to his teeming brain his
choice of theme could not have conferred
meaning on his brief life some lives are
meaningful because their effects endure
across many generations perhaps in the
form of words that
continue to be read with profit or joy
perhaps in the guise of material objects
or institutional structures enriching
the lives of many people the great
touched the lives of millions or
billions of people remote and unknown to
them as diet Emma once told Socrates
they have the best kinds of children yet
it's important to reject exceptionalism
the modern counterpart of ancient
elitism ordinary lives attained meaning
in the more local but no less important
differences they make ambitious young
Stephen Dedalus vows his resolve to
forge in the smithy of my soul the
uncreated conscience of my race Joyce
reintroduces him once his attempt to saw
has led him to share the fate of Icarus
and sets the bruised Steven beside a
different protagonist mr. Leopold Bloom
advertising canvasser whose ordinary
life for all its flaws may yet attain
work and meaning religious people might
concede that the features on which I
focused mark differences among human
lives while denying that they can confer
meaning autonomy only matters they might
think when it expresses the free
commitment to the transcendent
contributing to the lives of others
gains its significance from the
objective standing of human beings as
low sigh of value bound to one another
as children of a common parent no link
to the transcendent no meaning fear of
fine at you runs through the writings of
religious thinkers as sophisticated as
William James and Paul Tillich they
regard the problem of fine acute as
dooming any non-religious perspective
fear sometimes in fact secular
pessimists to whom the bounded impact of
any human existence entails the
absurdity of life pessimism might be
encapsulated in James's haunting image
of our predicament was that of people
living on a frozen lake surrounded by
cliffs over which there is no escape
fully aware that the ice is slowly
melting in the day on which they will
vanish without trace is drawing ever
religion is the answer to there or to
our cry for help but why should
impermanence undermine meaning I'll
counter James's image with a different
story toward the end of Thomas man's
late masterpiece dr. Faustus his focal
character that he posed are ugly and
labor Kuhn experiences in close
proximity the deaths of his father and
his father surrogate max fry gosh dude
labor Kuhn has taken up residence on the
Schrager steel family farm a place with
an uncanny resemblance to his childhood
home in buco and although his health
would not permit him to make the long
journey back to mourn his own father he
attends Schwager stills funeral
returning from the ceremony he is
greeted by the distinctive smell of the
old man's pipe and I'm gonna quote from
the novel that indoors said Adrien quite
a while perhaps as long as the house
stands it lingers on in buckle to the
period of our lingering afterwards
perhaps a little shorter or a little
longer that is what is called
immortality the ordinary unpretentious
endurance of max swagger still is partly
captured in the aroma impregnated in the
woodwork and the walls of the house in
which he has passed his entire life
eventually of course the odor will
dissipate the farm will be tended and
maintained by people who know Schrager
still only as a figure and faded
photographs the walls and fences he
built will decay and be replaced the
fields he ploughed and planted will be
newly configured and put to different
uses for a while though he will be vivid
in the memories of those who knew him
who was sustained by his labors and
comforted by his presence the fabric of
their lives initially left ragged by his
day will be rewoven in ways that
preserve and cherish the recollections
his commitment to maintain and improve
the farm his father left him and to pass
it on to his own son will be felt in the
early years after his death so much man
invites us to
suffice is for a kind of immortality I
accept his invitation this lingering is
enough to confer meaning on an ordinary
life
would there be some qualitative
difference if the impact of Schrager
Steel's life were considerably extended
if his achievements were as long-lived
as those of Keats or even implausibly if
his agricultural accomplishments were
recalled across the millennia as we
celebrate the Homeric epics were the
significance of his life be transformed
if we imagine the earth and the human
species and the farm and the memories of
max vigor still to last forever I don't
think so
what matters is the fact that a life has
a continuing connection to a world that
indoors beyond it like a stone cast into
a pool it leaves a series of ripples
behind sometimes more sometimes less and
it doesn't matter that the ripples
eventually fade away conceiving meaning
and immortality in this way enables
secular humanism to offer a more
complete answer to the problems posed by
death corresponding to the anguish of
premature death is the consolation of
the fulfilled life the truly lucky are
those who come to see that the project
singled out in their life themes have
been largely finished not completely of
course well there are always further
endeavors always loose ends while they
may take their current striving
seriously and hope for the joys brought
when those striving succeed reflection
may convince them that they've done
enough but if life ended now it wouldn't
subvert their most fundamental
aspirations a New Testament story
captures the attitude when the baby
Jesus is brought to the temple to be
circumcised he is seen and held by the
aged Simeon prompting the declaration
Anglican choirs sing as the nunc
dimittis Lord now lettest thou thy
servant depart in peace according to thy
word for mine eyes have seen thy
salvation
Simeon's reaction can be liberated from
the divine project he takes to have been
realized it can be felt
by anyone who recognizes that enough has
been done to elaborate his life theme
that more is unnecessary and that the
returns from further efforts would
diminish those left behind can't feel
the same equanimity how could they
they've lost a person whom they still
longed to see and touch and here yet
provided they have time to renew and
refashion their own life patterns their
awareness of the fulfilled life enables
them to integrate the memories of the
dead into their continuing relationships
and endeavors eventually other people
will occupy the spaces originally left
achingly blank nor will the new loves
constitute a betrayal for they will be
recognized as shaped by memories of
those once mourned the dead may be
regarded with joyful gratitude even with
something akin to reverence perhaps the
source of insistence on overcoming fine
a 2d is an argument my life could only
attain meaning from its effect on other
lives if those other lives themselves
were meaningful so there begins a
regress the other lives would obtain
their meaning from their impact on yet
further lives whose meaningfulness would
depend on their effects on yet more
remote people and so on and on but the
sequence can't proceed indefinitely
human life will eventually cease and all
James's ice dwellers will be drowned
there must be some last member of the
chain since this person can have no
impact on some subsequent meaningful
life her life is deprived of meaning
lack of meaning now seeps backward
through the entire sequence because
those in the n plus first place don't
enjoy meaningful lives the people at the
end stage don't have effects on
meaningful lives and hence their lives
are devoid of meaning but to state the
argument explicitly makes it evident how
to resist it the picture of something
acquiring meaning through relationship
to something else that already has
meaning is doomed from the start
especially if the some things are
qualitatively equivalent but meaning
lies in the relationship itself one life
may be meaningful
through its effects on others effects
that contribute to the possibility of
the lives affected developing
meaningfully even though contingent
factors subvert that development
shraeger steals life would remain
meaningful even if the fortunes of
family and farm gradually declined
across the subsequent generations even
if the property were eventually sold and
the descendants scattered in a very
different society nothing endures
forever but lives centered on extending
the existence of something people
treasure are not automatically deprived
of meaning by the fact of impermanence
purified religion sets against this
image of meaningful lives with local
short-lived effects an ostensibly
grander perspective independent of human
aspirations there's some eternal gold
and the meaning of individual lives
stems from their acquiescence in the
goal and the necessarily infinitesimal
contributions people make to it
transcending finer tude is purchased at
the cost cost of autonomy Mills
fundamental freedom the choice of one's
own good is subordinated to a cosmic
enterprise beyond human understanding
our autonomy is reduced to acceptance of
a remote venture in which we play bit
parts without knowing how our doings
contribute how our condition of
alienated labor confers meaning on what
we do is a mystery worse the ordinary
things that matter to people the staff
of meaningful lives don't receive their
value from any human concerns relations
to the lives of others are not
significance because extending and
expanding responsiveness is at the heart
of the ethical project rather acts of
caring nurturing sustaining and
protecting achieve their special status
from the terms of the cosmic enterprise
the yearning to transcend human fine
acute ends by restricting autonomy and
is stranger what is most centrally human
meaningful lives do require a connection
to something larger but not to anything
eternal or cosmic humanism of
both the potential meaningfulness of our
deeds and the finite character of their
impact endorsing the local immortality
recalled by man's protagonist humanism I
think can only be secular once they're
clearly in view the intellectual
problems posed for secular humanism by
mortality and meaning can be resolved
but practical difficulties remain many
surely most human lives don't go well
among the contemporary global population
millions if not billions struggle to
gather the necessities that enable them
and their children to continue from day
to day for many more secularists praise
of autonomous choice at one's own good
would be a tasteless joke statistics
indicate that religious adherents and
religious fervour flourish among the
people most vulnerable to life's
vicissitudes that shouldn't be
surprising religious doctrine and
religious community can provide hope but
the reversals of the present fragile
existence will somehow be compensated
they can also give opportunities for
mutual support and consolation even if
the promises of future rewards are
hollow the benefits brought by religious
community may be real because
substantive religious doctrines often
retain the prejudices inscribed by the
supposed epical authorities of the
tradition for example in their views of
the roles appropriate for women they can
intensify the confinement of autonomy
and erect further barriers to living a
meaningful life nevertheless religious
communities have often brought the
powerless together identifying shared
sources of oppression and combining
voices so that they could at last be
heard famously the civil rights movement
of the 1960s was grounded in the
church's led by eloquent preachers who
could galvanize their conflict
congregations less evident to many is
the social role religious communities
continued to provide the resources they
offer to families struggling to create
better opportunities
they're children in environments where
secular institutions are woefully
inadequate it doesn't have to be that
way
secular society might respond to the
problems of economic and social justice
honoring the egalitarian ideal of the
provision for all of the preconditions
for a meaningful life even the most
striking attempts to nurture all nascent
lives undertaken in Scandinavian
societies have fallen short of that
ideal the lapses of other affluent
societies in northern Europe or in Japan
in Canada Australia Britain and the
United States are successively more
glaring signifying at the latter end of
the continuum a willingness to treat
many lives as effectively disposable on
a global scale the predicament is even
worse central to my secular humanism is
a commitment to socio-economic justice
across the human species beyond
declaring abstract rights we should
demand that the world's resources be
shared so as to allow to all people the
opportunity for meaningful life however
the power the dedication to egalitarian
ideals there will always be lives that
do not go well disrupted by
contingencies beyond prediction or
control
there will be no utopia in which all
people enjoy the good life to which the
aristocrats of the ancient world aspired
but we can try to decrease the frequency
at which lives fall short when they go
awry there should be efforts at rescue
support for the person's search for a
new direction if the efforts fail that
is a genuine loss not to be glossed over
with false promises of some future
compensation this is the only life the
person has we should be committed to
Salvage not to salvation literalists
religions often do better far better
than secular institutions in responding
to the conditions that do many people -
lives marked by insecurity and confined
to narrow horizons but their efforts are
compromised by supposing present
failures to be redeemed in the here
laughter by affirming doctrines tainted
by traditional prejudices and by
commitments to exclusivity that lead to
interfaith conflict and perpetuation of
the material and social miseries they
endeavor to remedy religions that purify
the pertinent elements abandoning any
literal commitment immortality and the
traditional divisive prejudices do even
better secular humanists should see them
as allies even as leaders in an
ethically fundamental Enterprise
thinking of religions and religious
communities is only directed toward the
plight of the needy and oppressed
misses an important dimension of the
work they do connection to others is I
propose central to the meaningful life
but I've emphasized the simplest form of
connection pairwise relations between
individuals most meaningful lives
exhibit a more complex structure of
affiliations engaging with many others
in joint projects and sharing common
purposes is often central to people's
life themes it's important to them to
participate in common endeavors that the
endeavors proceeded through mutual
responsiveness and that they themselves
contribute to the eventual outcome today
most of us belong to societies in which
the web of associations is not simply
given as it was for our Paleolithic
ancestors or for the closely knit
villages of the pre-industrial world
contemporary people must seek community
religious institutions are often the
only places in which they find it
communities of believers connect their
members providing a sense of belonging
and of being together with others of
sharing problems and of working
cooperatively to find solutions
religious involvement doesn't merely
provide occasions to talk about
important issues although that itself is
valuable but also for conjoint action
sharing a religion whether literalistic
or purified can foster agreement on
goals not necessarily focused on the
liberation or socio-economic progress of
the faithful engaging in common pursuit
of a good endorsed by fellow strivers
and playing one's part
is often the source of the deepest
satisfactions there are similar
satisfactions to be found particularly
at some life stages in the narrower
circle of the family in nurturing
children and caring for loved ones in
developing individual friendships and
especially in sustaining friends through
times of adversity typically the spaces
in which rewarding into relations are
found are disjoint from the workplace
the sphere of most intense activity
nurses and teachers doctors and social
workers can participate daily in joint
efforts aimed at goals they and their
co-workers endorse is important research
scientists and statesmen may see
themselves as working with others to
improve the lot of millions yet the
dominant condition of the workers at the
modern world even at the Martin affluent
world is the one Marx diagnosed as
alienated labor the hours must be put in
not to reach any end assessed as
worthwhile by oneself or one's fellows
but simply so that something will be
produced to make enough money to pay the
wages and support the material basis of
the workers lives religion doesn't have
to be the main vehicle of community life
thoroughly secular societies can contain
structures enabling people to enter into
sympathetic relations with one another
to exchange views about topics that
concern the most to work together to
identify goals that matter to all
members of the group and to pursue those
ends through cooperative efforts authors
of contemporary manifestos that call for
freedom from religious delusions
typically belong to professional
communities with the important
dimensions the lack of similar secular
structures for others disappears from
their view in many parts of the affluent
world however particularly in the United
States there are no serious
opportunities outside the synagogues and
churches and mosques for fellowship with
all the dimensions religious communities
can provide even people who have little
time for any substantive religious
doctrine sometimes view the persistence
of religion in the modern world as a
welcome corrective to the dominance of
crass materials
their diagnosis rests on an important
insight
despite the usual talk of preserving the
spiritual aspects of our nature the core
perception recognizes the conditions of
modern life as distorting the autonomous
choice and pursuit of one's own good
diverting people from more meaningful
forms of existence they might have
pursued and enjoyed satisfaction of the
material needs of all the preconditions
of affording opportunities for
meaningful lives generates the quest for
efficient production and the unsparing
competition of the workplace the
secondary goal trickles down to
individual lives now seen in terms of
competition for material goods and for
the marks of status atomistic
individuals attempt to play the role of
Homo economicus not a role for which
people particularly well-suited family
life provides some refuge for meaningful
projects although these two may be
misshapen by assumptions that the young
must above all be equipped for the
competition to come beyond the family
projects my only the goals of
accumulating goods and prestige and of
enjoying evanescent pleasures goals the
ancients already knew to be inadequate
aspirations for a flourishing life
religion is rightly seen as a corrective
to the materialism of the age not
because it draws attention to any real
spiritual realm nor because of the
correctness of any specific religious
doctrine no matter how minimal but
because of the importance to us of a
multi-dimensional form of community life
for large swathes of contemporary
affluent societies religious communities
are the principal places in which shared
ethical life can be found secular
humanism faces no intellectual problems
in accounting for the potential
meaningfulness of human existence the
real difficult is a practical grounded
in the need to overcome aspects of the
contemporary world unnecessarily limit
the lives of many people resolving them
is in part a matter of rethinking
economic life in institutions
turning to a conception of political
economy that frames its standards in the
fundamental currency of values not in
the secondary goals of monetary profit a
central task is to devise secular
substitutes for the multi-dimensional
community life religions have bestowed
on their followers attempts to solve
that problem may seek inspiration in the
successful strategies of the world's
religions as the most prominent ventures
in fashioning secular community
Unitarian churches societies for ethical
culture and Jewish community centers
have all done if the initial results
seem pallid imitations of the religious
prototypes lacking the powerful rites
with their resonant words and uplifting
music it's worth recalling that the
religions have had centuries of practice
secular humanists should remember that
experiments require time to make them
work and they should pursue the
important practical goal with
perseverance and patience thank you
Thank You professor Kitchener I want to
invite questions if they could be
directed by coming down the aisle to the
front and using the microphones that
would be wonderful
I'll just open with one I love the line
about the secular humanism has no
ethical problems or intellectual
problems it's practical problems and
your entire talk I was thinking a lot
about latter-day saints for whom the
concept of celestial marriage was so
central to initially bringing people
into the religion you'd be married in
perpetuity but one of the key elements
of the religion and deed to this day
when you see sociological studies of
Mormons they speak about how it's not
that I will be rewarded with being with
these people for the rest of life in
some ideal state it's that I will get to
continue the relational work that brings
me such great spiritual pleasure in the
next life with this person so the work
continues in the world beyond so I guess
I wanted to think with you as you ended
the top inviting us to think about the
formation of new kinds of secular
institutions and I guess I wanted you to
think aloud about when you what you have
in mind for those kinds of alternative
spaces where multi-dimensional
relational life can be fostered without
an imperative of perpetuity what do you
when you think of that what are the ones
that you come to mind for you what are
the spaces that come to mind given that
you could say at the end this will take
time it's experimental
no force nothing yeah I mean look as
somebody who comes out of a religious
childhood I am struck whenever I go into
the existing kinds of cultural spaces in
which humanist groups or unit or
self-styled Unitarian groups try to come
together and and sort of focus
themselves on some sort of joint
endeavor some joint project and try to
construct ways in which this will be
conveyed and made meaningful in their
borrowings from the from if not the
words the structures of the religious
rites
and it seems to me that one thing that
that is difficult really to convey here
is the the importance of what I called
the kind of immortality that Thomas
Martin allows you the the importance of
the image of your life as having these
reverberations that go on even though
they cease and I think actually
overcoming that their argument about the
importance of an infinite sequence of
activities is a crucial step in in
finding ways to structure this kind of
joint focus on ethical activity so that
it will work as it were more
meaningfully I don't know whether you've
ever been to the Society for ethical
culture or to Unitarian certainly I mean
it looks just frankly imitative and when
you see it as imitative if you see it
automatically as giving up something
that the that you know richer religious
conceptions can offer and that's why it
seems to me so important that this issue
all of our fine it ood be addressed as
it were at the center to see ourselves
as part of something that goes on
without seeing ourselves as something as
part of something that goes on we need
in a sense a way of finding ways to
celebrate that and so so I think
actually the what I said in terms of the
of the solution to the intellectual
problem is something that I would put at
the very heart of the the experimental
process of designing these institutions
but I want to stick very much with what
I said at the very end you know rune
wasn't built in a day and the rights
that are so powerful in various
religions are you know they're they are
the result of you know generations it
seems to me of fine-tuning and it will
take I think humanists culture a long
time to work out the exact ways into
which in which to make this message of
the importance to one another of
relatedness and of knowing that that
relatedness event eventually dissipates
and seeing that as something to be
celebrated and understood and and not to
mourn the fact that that there isn't the
indefinite continuation thank you
hi my name is Tom Platt I I have had
some curiosity about your reassurance to
others dealing with their own worked at
mortality for example I don't know if
Huxley had a chance to interact with
this son who died let's say you had a
grandchild who was fearful of I was
dying of a terminal illness and was
fearful and didn't share your
intellectual maturity obviously you have
to play that one by ear but I mean I
wondered if you had any general thoughts
of being put in this position of
providing say reassurance to a small
child who was fearful of dying well I
have had children so I know what it's
like when children suddenly discover
that that that life doesn't go on
forever and of course you have you can't
you can't say to such children the kinds
of things that I was saying today that
would be that would be silly but what
you want well it would be silly and
cruel what you want to say the kinds of
things that will help them grow into the
kinds of beings who can one day I hope
come to come to see things from a
perspective where they can which is like
hoxsey's where they can think they can
they can look at they can look at death
calmly and they can they can feel its
pain and they can and they can still
resolve to continue the course on which
they've set themselves I find something
admirable in what he what he did in
refusing whatever consolation it was
that Kings they offered him and of
course what he did was not only to
devote himself to his remaining children
but also to devote himself to the
projects the intellectual projects that
was central to his life and I do think I
want to place emphasis on one thing that
I said that there is perhaps for you
perhaps for me we're not so young as we
used to be there is I think this
invisible idea of the moment that
comes in your life when you say that's
enough I could if I would like it to go
on but it doesn't have to go on any
further there's nothing that that
remains
there's nothing crucial that remains
unfinished about my life that's why I
drew attention to vape to the story of
Simeon and in the New Testament but as
far as what to say to children I think
you know I am not the right person to
ask about that you need to talk to
somebody who's who's expert on on child
psychology but as parents you know we
tend to work these things out for
ourselves you probably did and I did two
or gathered together the comments you
made about autonomy okay so I followed I
feel follow mill and Humboldt and can't
hear right I I think it's very important
for a meaningful and worthwhile life
that it be your life that is something
you choose something you identify with
so I think that the preconditions for a
meaningful life are that you don't get
coerced into even subtly coerced into
taking on some particular role that your
society thinks is the fitting one for
you to to play and that you have as it
were the opportunity to explore and to
understand a large range of options this
is all sort of standard I think standard
mill now as I think about the what one
might think of as the religious answer
to this where your your life is seen as
in relation to something to some sort of
cosmic project that seems to me a kind
it a kind of
rather grande version of the familiar
practice in many human societies of
assigning roles at Birth based say on
status in the society or the or the
caste or whatever it seems to me the
same kind of alienating coercion
coercive suppression of autonomy which
is why I talked about it in the
religious context as I mean I from my
secular perspective the religious
solution just is a non solution because
I think Kant and Humboldt and Mill were
actually right about this condition of
autonomy so even if you think about
yourself as contributing to some to some
cosmic project and of course it's an
ironic twist of the finite argument that
if you're contributing to that project
your contribution can only be
infinitesimal that's why it shows that
word rather deliberately you on my
account of how religion works at its
best the most that can be made of that
is you you make this this infinitesimal
contribution to something I know not
what and that strikes me as really at
odds with a precondition for the
worthwhile life which is why I said in
perhaps this rather over assertive and
not very friendly fashion that humanism
humanism can only be secular hi my name
is Ike sweat Lutz and I have a question
about the possibility of the continuity
of non religious communities to the same
extent that religious communities have
been continuous because it seems like
even if you admit that human life is
finite the fact that there is an
infinite transcendence associated with
the religion is in a large part some of
the reasons why the most enduring
communities that have existed throughout
history our are based on religion and
not based on nationality and not based
on culture and things like that and even
the less Orthodox streams of religion
that have given cultural enterprises
like the JCC's you mentioned
have still acknowledged a commitment to
that to the to the infinite Divine Being
that extends infinitely into the past an
infinitely into the future and and I'm
wondering how you can how you can
guarantee the continuity of a community
that doesn't in some heart believe in
something transcendently infinitely
larger than itself okay that's a
terrific question and it brings me back
actually to the first question that was
posed because it seems to me that this
does require a reorientation I think one
youth you think of community as founded
on a religious community has founded on
something that in indoors indefinitely
and is always there and is always larger
than me and I want to replace that with
the idea of community as larger than the
individual larger than even than the
social group that is brought together in
this community but not but not permanent
and I think that's why that's why I put
at the center of my lecture this this
story of this this this piece from
Thomas Mann's novel because I think it's
very important to make this conceptual
shift from the infinitely greater and
enduring with which I connect myself to
the something larger than me that and to
see that as being as it were central to
the formation of community now you
guarantees are not to be had here
I don't believe in guarantees and I
don't even believe in guarantees for
your religious communities but that the
point is and this is in the spirit of
what I said in the last sector about the
ethical project the the commitment to an
evolving project which may change its
forms so one shouldn't be I think taken
aback in one's commitment to a community
that indoors but probably won't endure
forever by the thought that that may
need to be reconstituted in the future
but that's all part of the Hume
project and that also has to be woven in
now of course it's a very you know if
you say there is this one thing and we
are going to be we are going to be
connected with that whatever you have a
particular virtue you have the virtue of
you know certain sustaining things but
the corresponding vice is that there may
be moments when these communities and
societies need reorganization when for
the as it were for the development of of
the of the value of human lives it would
actually be better and I think that so I
think that the the apparent gain
instability is offset perhaps by a
threat of rigidity so that's a
complicated answer to your question it's
a very good question
but I do think it reminds me of what I
wanted to say to the to Katherine's
first question which is really that the
at the center of all of this is the idea
of the connection between me and
something much larger than myself but
not infinite
yeah
okay so I'm I mean I'm very much in
sympathy with that because my last
lecture might lecture before this one
puts at the center of the ethical
project the idea of techniques for
developing our responsiveness to others
and it seems to me that that is that
that is a crucial feature of ethical
advance and yeah yeah yeah right so this
is but this seems to me not an
intellectual problem again but but a
practical problem it's a practical
problem about the structures in which
this kind of expansion of ourselves to
come into relationship with others can
really flourish and and you're
absolutely right and perhaps I should
have made perhaps I should see this I
have to think about it as a problem as
deep as or a deep aspect of the problems
about community that I was struggling to
articulate at the end I mean I think the
problems I was looking at are the
problems of people being able to find
spaces in which they can engage in these
these joint projects and set up these
structures what what you're suggesting
is
there's there's something else that the
church does very well which is providing
a structure within which others altruism
can be accepted and thereby encouraging
you know the full of development of that
that seems to me a very interesting
insight actually good thank you sorry
for that you spoke a little bit about
the recluse who sits and watches blades
of grass counts them yeah it's like
classic philosophical example I'm sorry
I was wondering if you could speak a
little bit more about your thoughts of
conception of a meaningful life that
focuses on experiencing and absorbing
sort of the beauty of the world as
opposed to contributing to it or placing
Allison - yeah I mean this is perhaps
this is a prejudice on my part but I'm
going to be I'm gonna dig in my heels
about it I think I think if you are on
your own no matter how much you
contemplate no matter how much poetry
goes through keeps keeps his teeming
brain if he doesn't write it down and
that's not a meaningful life this is
this is if you like development of the
anti hedonism which runs through the
good life the good life literature I
mean there's a famous you're too young
to have seen the movie sleeper probably
Woody Allen's sleeping as the you know
moment in which he discovers this this
machine into which you can go and you
can just have pleasure beyond right it's
called the orgasm uh Tron right and and
he goes inside and it rocks like this
and I mean look the ancients saw that
that the orgasmatron was not not the
solution to the problem of the good life
and I think that one's own contemplation
of the you know
one's own act of private creation is
still not enough it has to be it has to
reach out and touch others this is this
is in a certain sense on part of this
general theme of questions that is
coming up I mean people are saying okay
so how do you how do you make
substitutes in various ways for this
relationship to something which is
permanent or enduring that's the that's
the source of this extremely good
question that came from here and the
answer seems to me to be the substitute
for the idea of something that for all
times excuse endures to which you're
connected the idea of your being
connected to something but India's at
times when you're not no longer present
making a difference to others so I'm
really I'm really committed to that
lives matter when they touch others life
so solitaries solitaries don't make it
even if they don't count blades of grass
and devote themselves to you know
high-minded thinking about the beauties
of nature
you know depravity on Thursday